Hi Guys,
so um,
we're going to talk about the brain
today.
Last lecture I talked to you a little
bit about construct validation and what
it means to measure something.
And so we're gonna take a bit of a
detour.
So I told you about measurement problems
last time.
If you do your measurement properly in
psychometrics,
if you're studying personality,
if you're studying individual
differences,
there are roughly six things that you
can discover and they can be broken up
different ways.
That's the big five model,
extroversion and neuroticism,
agreeableness,
conscientiousness,
openness,
and they can be subdivided as you should
know because it makes you read the
paper,
the sub divided them into 10 APP turns
out to be quite useful,
but for now we'll just presume that
there are five.
And then the other factor of human
function that's pretty easy to derive
and measure his Iq.
Now,
Iq likely nests under openness.
Openness looks like it's something
roughly like intellect,
which is interested in ideas,
but that's probably an ability with
ideas,
but that's probably measured better by
an Iq test.
So if I asked her how smart you are and
you say you're pretty smart,
that would give you a relatively high
score on the intellect scale,
but if I tested your Iq,
I will get a better measure that not so
in some sense Iq nests inside the big
five model.
But you can think about it as a separate
thing and I think it's reasonable to do
that.
So,
you know,
it depends on what you're up to.
Fundamentally.
Now,
when the big five was first invented,
invented or discovered,
depending on how you look at it,
as I mentioned briefly as well,
it was brute force statistics basically.
So the idea behind the big five is that
the,
uh,
it's called the lexical hypothesis
hypothesis is that because human traits
are so important to us because we want
to understand ourselves and perhaps even
more importantly,
we want to understand other people and
because we have language,
there's a reasonable probability that
we've encapsulated the structure of
human personality within our language.
And so if you analyze the linguistic
representations properly,
then perhaps you can extract out the
central personality features.
And that's basically what the lexical
hypothesis is and it's important to know
the lexical hypothesis and it's a bit
more sophisticated than that because it
basically presumed that you can extract
out route valid information about
personality from adjectives,
descriptive adjectives from phrases and
from questions,
and you'll get the same basic
dimensional structure regardless of
which of those techniques you use.
And that turns out to be true for all
intents and purposes.
Now,
the lexical hypothesis depends on its
validity,
depends for its validity on the initial
claim,
that personality is accurately
represented within the structure of
language.
And so one of the things I would say is
that there is a week paid five
hypothesis and a strong big five
hypothesis.
Okay?
The week big five hypothesis is that in
so far as you use language to describe
personality,
personality has a five factor structure
that's reliably extractable.
Now,
the strong,
Big Five theory is that no,
no personality has a five factor
structure and it's accurately
represented in language,
but when you pull out the structure from
language,
what you're pulling out is actually
representative of genuine personality.
Now the week hypothesis is I would say
it's established and it's worth knowing
because what it,
what it means is that if you invent a
questionnaire that has anything to do
with self description,
it might be self description at multiple
different levels of analysis,
like values for example,
and instead of just adjectives or
attitudes instead of just adjectives.
I mean these categories are sort of of a
unclear.
What's the difference between your
attitude and your temperament?
Well,
you know,
it's usually defined by the sentence
that you used the word Zen,
right?
You extract out the words,
they sort of stand there alone.
They don't.
It's very difficult to clarify their
meaning.
Anyways.
The lexical hypothesis I think is one of
the most well established.
It's one of the most well validated
claims in psychology.
I think it might be the most validated
claim apart from maybe the work that is
extracted Iq out from cognitive
questions.
And uh,
basically it was brute force statistics.
You know,
people develop different lists of
adjectives and you can complain in some
ways about how they did it and we'll
talk about that later.
But because they tried to throw out the
evaluative words like good and evil,
for example,
those aren't in the big five.
So they tried to only use adjectives
that didn't necessarily seem to be like
highly or valued or devalued.
So introvert and extrovert,
while they're opposites,
but you know,
is it better to be an introvert?
It's better to be the extroverts like,
well,
it's not obvious.
So those were all the words that cover
that dimension can be kept in because
there's no value judgements associated
with it.
And the originators of the big five
theory wanted to keep it as free of
values as possible.
Now that's already a hypothesis,
right?
It's a hypothesis that you can come up
with an accurate description of human
personality,
even if you eliminate all the words that
have to do that are clearly vacancy.
And uh,
we did an experiment here a while back,
that was pretty interesting.
We got hold of a data set of descriptive
adjectives and we put all the evaluative
words back in,
so,
you know,
like nasty and horrible and awkward and
a pool.
And um,
and then the good words as well,
you know,
moral,
pleasant,
uplifting all of those things and,
and we had people rate people they liked
and people they didn't like using that
expanded list and we got a real
archetype in some sense of the hateable
person and a tremendous number of the
words that were used came from the value
of dementia.
So I think that when you throw out the
value of words,
you actually throw out a lot of what
people actually use descriptive words to
describe because you know,
when you like someone or don't like
someone if someone's likable or
unlikable,
that's pretty important phenomena.
You know what I mean?
You hang around the people you like
generally speaking and you don't
associate with the people you don't
like.
So it's a fundamental choice,
but we'll talk about that later because
there's reasons that happened and the
reasons were valid and it's not that
easy to fix it.
And besides that,
the standard five factor model has all
sorts of utility.
So,
but you need to know what its strengths
are and it's limitations are now
hypothetically,
what you knew to draw out the five
factor model is you take magine the sec
of all descriptive adjectives and then
you take a random sample of those
descriptive adjectives so that it's not
biased.
You don't use all of them because you
know,
if you ask someone to describe
themselves on a questionnaire using all
the adjectives we have that described
personality,
they'd be there for a day.
And so that's not very efficient.
So you want to take a random sample,
maybe you only sample the words that
people are most likely to use.
So for example,
if you go online and you'll find that
there are word frequency tables,
you know,
and most of your language,
most of the,
about 500 words covers about 80 percent
of what you say.
So,
you know,
and I don't remember what the lexicon of
the typical person is.
I think it's in the neighborhood of
3,500
words,
but that might be wrong,
but there's like 750,000
words in the English language.
You know,
it's an omnivorous language,
it just pulled words in from all over
and so you hardly use any of those words
you know,
and there's ones that are used
extraordinarily infrequently.
So what you could do is you could look
at the total set of adjectives and then
you can pull out,
you know,
identify the ones,
the ones that are used,
you know,
the thousand most frequently used words
and that probably covered 95 percent of
the territory and then you could pick
out random set of a hundred and you
could administer it to people and then
you could factor,
analyze it,
administered to lots of people.
Then you factor analyze it and you get
five relatively clear and stable factors
and the most,
the one that comes out first,
so it's,
it's the dominant factor in some sense
or the easiest to measure are maybe the
best represented language or something
like that.
It's extroversion versus introversion
and extroversion is a positive emotion
dimension and it's associated with
enthusiasm and assertiveness and
assertive people will say they'll
dominate the conversation with language
or they'll well that basically that's
the right way to think about it.
I'm enthusiastic people,
they're up for anything,
you know,
they're the ones that are always smiling
and telling jokes and having parties and
that sort of thing.
And generally extroverts really liked to
be around people so they're happy.
They're gregarious,
they're assertive,
they're enthusiastic,
they're noisy,
they blink more than introverts out.
Why that is.
I have no idea,
but apparently they do.
So if you notice something blinking a
lot,
you can assume that they're extroverts.
If they're not conscientious,
like you know,
there's this idea of people being
impulsive.
It's very badly defined term.
So when you hear a psychologist talking
about impulsivity,
the first thing you could realize is
they don't know.
You don't know what the hell they're
talking about because probably there's
no such thing as impulsivity,
but extroverted people who are not very
conscientious tend to.
That's one of the things that you might
think about as associated with
impulsivity.
There's all sorts of other things though
too,
so,
um,
okay,
so there a positive emotion dimension
and that's extroversion and there's a
negative emotion,
emotion,
dimension and that's neuroticism and
neurotic.
Neuroticism seems to break down into
something like withdrawal and volatility
and volatile people are touching so you
know,
they'll,
they'll react quite a lot if something
negative happens.
So if you tease them,
they might get upset or if you start
fighting with them and that sort of
provocative way instead of sort of
calming everything down there,
just ramp it up.
And if there's two of you that are
volatile and you're having a
conversation and the conversation goes a
little bit,
you know,
into unpleasant territory,
you can really get each other going.
So yes,
like in terms of the hero and I can turn
those states both.
Oh,
both.
Yeah.
I mean that's part of the problem with
using the word emotion because there's
an emotion,
an internal state or a set of behaviors.
And the answer to that as far as we can
tell,
it's both.
So now I'm going to start talking about
extroversion and neuroticism.
And part of the reason for that is
because I think the evidence for the
relationship between those traits and
the way the brain functions functions is
in some sense the clearest.
Now you remember the baby five were
extracted out using statistical
procedures,
right?
So there's no reason to assume
necessarily that the traits would bear
any straightforward relationship to
brain function because they didn't.
They weren't derived from analysis of
brain function,
at least not directly they were at.
They were extracted from analysis of
linguistic representations of other
peoples and your own behavior.
But it turns out that there's quite a
concordance between certain elements of
neuro psychological theory and the
positive and negative emotional traits,
extroversion and neuroticism.
And so what I'm going to do today is I'm
gonna.
I'm gonna.
Talk to you about how positive and
negative emotions are are instantiated
in some sense neurologically.
But I'm going to put that in a,
in a broader picture of brain function.
Because while,
because first of all,
why not?
And second,
because a lot of the things I'm going to
tell you about the brain today will sort
of retroactively shed light on some of
the clinical theories that we've already
talked about.
So,
so which is nice,
you know,
because when one of the ways that you
find out if something is true,
and this is something we also talked
about during the last lecture,
is that it manifests itself even when
you use different measurement
techniques.
And so you had this statistical
derivation which basically took place.
It really started to accelerate,
I would say first in the 19 sixties and
then in the 19 eighties it made a big
comeback in the 19 eighties,
but paralleling that were theories of
brain development and they weren't
really the scientists that were doing
the one sort of research really work
communicating with the scientists that
were doing the other kind of research.
So they were methodologically separate.
They use different techniques as well.
They weren't talking back and forth much
and they were using different
measurement techniques.
So if they both come up with the same
thing,
then you think,
oh,
well there's probably something to that
because you know,
for the sighted people discovered it and
the people who could hear discovered it.
It's the same kind of idea.
So,
and you know,
this has been worked out in a fair bit
of detail over the last 30 years really.
And so,
um,
the,
the papers that you're supposed to read
with their difficult papers,
uh,
I believe you're reading gray,
which is a model of the limbic system
and Basal Ganglia applications to
anxiety and schizophrenia.
Um,
um,
I think you have goals and behavior.
That's the carbon shyer paper.
I put the Swanson paper in as optional.
That's cerebral hemisphere regulation of
motivated behavior.
That is a tough paper.
And so is the gray paper and it's partly
because of these guys,
both of them graze paper is that is a
distillation of a very,
very thick book that's very,
very difficult.
And that's been written twice.
It was published first in 1982 and then
again in 1999.
It's a brilliant book.
It's had a tremendous impact on
psychology.
Gray was one of those people who,
he was so damn smart.
It's just painful,
you know,
I mean his reference list,
I don't know how many papers are in his
reference list,
like 2000.
And one of the really weird things about
gray that makes them stand out among
scientists is he actually read all those
and more than that,
he understood them.
And so that's really something.
And so greatest book on anxiety.
Um,
he's,
he,
he did a lot of work with animal
behavior.
I'll tell you if you want like solid
psychological information about how the
brain works.
The people that you pay attention to are
the animal,
the,
the people who are studying animal
behavior and animal grades.
They know what they're doing there.
So methodologically careful.
They're very,
very reliable and the human neuro
psychologists and the people who use pet
standards and Mris and all that thing.
There are way,
way,
way behind the animal researchers
because the animal researchers can just
get in there at a lot higher resolution
and they can do much more stringent
experiments and they tend to be more
methodological,
careful and more scientifically minded.
So anyways,
the gradebook is a brilliant book.
It's very.
It took me like four months to read that
damn book and I was.
I really had to take it apart because he
probably had 30 years of work into it,
something like that.
And like he worked a lot in 30 years,
you know,
he did a lot of experimentation and he
read lot and so he built a bottle of
the,
of the brain's function that was based
on partly on Russian neuropsychology,
partly on cybernetic theory,
hardly on animal behavior,
partly on neuropsychopharmacology.
And so that's the study of how drugs
affect behavior and cognition and then
partly partly from a higher order
conceptual perspective.
And then he stacked all those things up,
one on top of the other to make sure
that the picture was the same at every
single level of analysis.
It's absolutely brilliant work.
And it took the social psychologist,
like they really started thinking about
gray,
although he published his book in 1982,
they probably started thinking about the
great seriously in about 2005,
so it took 23 years for his book to
start to make its widescale entrance
into the more general psychological
community.
And anyways,
and so you're going to read this paper,
which is a model of the limbic system
and Basal Ganglia and it's a distillery.
It's 30 years,
were distilled into the book and then
that was distilled into this paper.
So you know,
it's rough going.
And then the Swanson paper,
he's another guy,
same kind of guy.
He's a developmental neuro anatomist.
And if you're really interested in
psychology,
I would really recommend reading those
papers because like they're hard going.
But if you get it,
you have this substrata of knowledge
underneath you that's really firmed.
And I rated like Swanson's paper.
The guy's a genius.
And what's so cool about Swanson's paper
is that if you talked to human neuro
psychologists,
you'll find that they're biased towards
the cerebral cortex.
And there's sort of.
I think there's sort of an
anthropomorphic pride that goes along
with that.
It's like,
well,
how are we different from animals?
Well,
you know,
we've got thumbs and not great,
hooray for the thumbs and you stand up,
right?
And,
but if you look at us neurologically,
the big differences that we have this
tremendously expanded cerebral cortex,
especially the prefrontal cortex.
And so then people think,
well,
because you know,
that's one of the things that
differentiates us from animals and it's
relatively evolutionarily modern because
the human brain really,
really developed rapidly over the last 2
million years that it's like king of the
brain in some sense,
and it's the place where all the
complicated things happen and that's
just not right.
Because like breathing,
that's complicated.
That's why you don't get to control it
voluntarily and keeping your heart
going.
That's complicated too.
And so you don't get to have a decision
about that.
Your brain has made that automatic like
millions of years ago because there's
just no way you're going to get
voluntary control over something that's
that vital,
you know?
So assuming that newer brain areas do
more complex things is in some ways I
think that's actually precisely
backwards.
It's the old brain areas that have been
around for 100,
$100,
million years.
Those damn things are smart and that's
why they've survived for so long and why
they're distributed and into so many
different species.
You know,
like you,
your brain is somewhat like a lobster's
brain.
It's a lot like a mouse brain and it's a
lot like a rat brain and you might
think,
well the rapper and isn't a very good
model of a human brain because after all
their rats.
But one thing I can tell you is that a
rat brain is a way better model of a
human brain.
Then your model of a human brain is a
model of the human brain.
You know what I mean?
It's like people think of the brain
while they have a dopey model.
Using Iraq as an example,
of course it's,
it's often some ways because rats can't
talk for example,
but there are so many levels of analysis
where you.
You might as well be a wrap,
you know,
technically speaking,
that neuropharmacology,
for example,
it's very,
very similar.
The function of the neurotransmitters,
the basic anatomy of the structures,
like there's a tremendous amount of
overlap and so you might as well go for
the commonalities among brains before
you focusing on the differences because
in some sense that way you get the basic
architecture right now.
Now one of the things that's really
interesting about Swanson and this makes
him and he's not a neuropsychologist and
he's not really even a psychologist.
He's a developmental neuro anatomist and
so there's lots of ways of piecing of
chopping up the brain,
you know,
to look at it because it's a really
complicated thing.
It's like saying,
well,
how many ways can you divide up a city
to analyze it?
Well,
there's,
there's endless numbers of ways that you
can divide up the city to look at it.
And there's.
It's the same with the brain,
you know,
because it's infinitely subdivided will
in some sense,
certainly all the way down to the
molecular structures.
And then even at higher order levels,
you know,
because it's so complex and it's
hierarchically structured,
you can just divide it up in all sorts
of different ways.
And so at higher levels of resolution
there isn't even that much agreement on
how to name the parts.
Now what the developmental
neuroanatomists do is that they look at
how the brain develops in uteral over
time.
So because it's a developing thing that
sort of unfold like a flower unfold,
you know,
and you can track how the,
which part of the early brain turns into
the later braid.
And so you can get some sense of the
like,
it's like an evolutionary tree,
you know,
if these three parts grew out of this
part,
then you can assume that there's some
commonality between them.
And that can also help you figure out
how to divide up the brain.
And so that's one of the things that
Swanson does.
But the other thing he does,
which I really liked,
is that instead of looking at the brain
from the top down,
which is what human psychologist tend to
do because they concentrate on st
language.
And you know,
higher order cognitive functions,
which we think of as complex,
but you think they're not that damn
complex,
you know,
like a computer can do mathematics so
much better than you that there's not
even any comparison,
you know,
and it won't be very long before.
A lot of the things that we think of as
abstract cognition are things that
computers are going to be able to do,
right?
They just want to go tournament for
example,
and the computers are now better.
Even your pc is better at playing chess
than probably anyone in this room.
And the really high end computers are
better at playing chess that anyone who,
who lives and so computers are catching
up damn fast,
but you'll notice that they don't do
things like bus tables in restaurants
because it turns out that's really hard.
You know,
when you think about it,
it's hard.
You know,
you're carrying different size loads all
the time.
You have to interact socially with
people properly.
You have to stay the hell out of the
way.
You have to exactly time when you're
going to come to the table,
you know you have to,
you have to move extraordinarily
efficiently,
especially as the place gets busy,
you know,
there's a lot of demands on you to do
that job effectively and you know,
we think about it as a low end job,
but it's not automated.
The low end jobs are the ones that are
going to be automated first and it's not
obvious that they're going to be the
things that we associated with low end
labor,
you know,
it's just the,
well now Swanson's did with the nervous
system.
I,
I was so happy when I found this paper
because he did exactly what the nervous
system,
what piaget did with children.
He showed how the nervous system builds
self from the bottom up and so swanson
and lays right on top of piaget.
It's lovely.
And then the other thing that's wants
and does very,
very nicely as the elucidates a lot of
the Freudian presuppositions,
you know,
so Freud of course talk about the ID and
the ID is this sort of like the archaic
brain in some sense.
You know,
it's all,
we're all your primal impulses alert and
you know,
he called that one thing that in while
you might say,
well,
is there an IED in the brain?
And the answer is well,
vaguely vaguely the,
the brain does differ in terms of the,
of the age of it's sub components and as
you go deeper into the brain and closer
to the spine,
the brain areas get find a genetically
older and the more phylogenetically
genetically older areas of the brain
which are underneath the cortex.
They have their own little circuits,
you know,
and there's some commonality between
them and they do govern tribal.
I think of them as primal
subpersonalities.
It's,
and we've talked about that before.
It's better than thinking about them as
drives or goals or anything like that
because not only do they do they do,
they,
they're,
they're sets of associated behaviors,
but they're not just that.
There are also ways of looking at the
world and ways of thinking about the
world.
So you know,
if you're angry,
it's not like you're,
you're being driven to use your fists.
That's not how it works.
What happens is that the angry
subpersonality comes out,
you know,
and it does a whole bunch of things,
it's got its own state of arousal.
It's characterized both by positive and
negative emotion,
which is something that's quite peculiar
about anger because it's both a
defensive reaction and an aggressive
forward moving behavior and it has a
viewpoint like it's a biased viewpoint.
If you're angry with someone,
all you can see about them is how damn
irritating they are and how much they
need to be defeated,
you know,
roughly speaking.
And so it's a whole personality.
Now.
It's a one dimensional personality has
all.
It's really God is anger and that's not
enough to solve every problem,
but you can't think about it as a drive
exactly because it's also because it's
not deterministic,
you know,
it's even when you're angry,
you have a range of choices to make.
Now there are circumscribed by the fact
that you're angry,
you know,
but,
but it's best to think about it as a sub
personality.
I think you just get a lot farther that
way.
Now what Swanson did,
you know how Psj talked about children,
infants,
they start out with a few fundamental
reflexes,
right?
That they're sort of born with,
including the ability to use their mouth
and they're telling me as an exploratory
a device and then they have certain
reflexes that they can manifest right
away and then they have the ability to
modify those reflexes and so as far as
piaget was concerned,
that was enough to get the ball rolling.
It was sorta like the child was booting
up across time.
It's got some,
you know,
outside of the operating system,
you've got some bare processes in your
computer that get it started enough so
the operating system can turn on.
It sort of unfolds up into something
complex.
Well,
that's sort of what human beings do
across time.
They start out with these basic reflexes
that are simple movements and then they
learn how to modify the movements and
then they learn how to chain the
movements together and then they learn
how to use the chain movements as tools
in some sense as embodied tools to
pursue to to allow these biologically
determined subpersonalities to operate
in the world with some chance of
success.
Okay,
now,
and you can,
you can layer that onto the nervous
system,
so partly what's happening when you get,
when you get these basic movements down,
the ones that are now automatic,
like your ability to grip and your
ability to do this with your hands and
all the.
All the basic sub routines you have with
your body.
Those are automatized.
They're.
They're made into little machines and
lot of them run spinal,
so you know because what you think in
some sense is that if you're walking,
you're thinking about walking in some
way.
That's how you walk.
It's like,
that's not right.
What happens is you orient yourself to a
goal and in some sense you just
disinhibit the system that knows how to
walk and then it more or less does it
automatically and you know you direct it
and you can modify what it's doing if
there's an error,
but you kind of know that,
right?
You drive to school or you drive
somewhere you're familiar to.
You don't even even necessarily remember
the drive.
If you've done it 50 times,
it's because you're basically in some
sense you just sequencing automated
behaviors and are good thing too because
if you didn't have those automated
expert behaviors at hand,
you wouldn't know how to drive because
it's.
You're just not smart.
You know the time when you drive most
consciously is when you first learned
how to drive.
Well,
you don't want a conscious thriver.
You want an unconscious expert driver
whose consciousness is monitoring the
world for anything unexpected.
That's what you want.
So,
and that's the case for almost
everything you do.
If you have to become conscious of what
you're doing,
the probability that you don't do it
very well,
it's really high.
And you know that because maybe you're
talking to someone happens when I'm
lecturing,
sometimes if I'm not really on top of
things,
I'll get self conscious and that's a
terrible thing to have happened when you
lecture,
you know,
it just makes you stumble.
If it's going well,
I know where I'm going and I'd have all
these little routines,
you know,
that our stories and things that I know
that they just automatically sequence.
All I have to do is point the lecture in
the right direction and you know,
the things that are logically associated
with,
uh,
the direction of the lecture will,
they'll come up there,
they're primed in some sense.
And so Swanson helped me understand the
functions of the lower part of the brain
quite well.
And then to map that onto piaget and l,
one of the things he helped me
understand was just exactly how
sophisticated the lower parts of the
brain are.
The more automatic parts.
Now the behaviorists used to believe
that or did believe and still believe to
some degree,
that a lot of your behavior is
reflexive.
And the radical behavior is the guys
from the fifties,
but more or less made the case that even
complex behavior among animals is
nothing but the chaining together a
automatic reflexes.
So it was deterministic chain of of
reflexes.
Well,
you do have reflex actions,
you know,
so if you touch a hot stove,
you'll jerk your hand away and your
brain isn't involved in that.
It's just your spinal cord that's
involved in that.
Now your brain's involved when the pain
hits.
And maybe that's so that you stopped
doing it in the future,
but you're the conscious part of your
brain is too slow to get your hand away
from the,
from the stove in time.
And so what's happening in your body in
some senses that you have these multiple
layers of neurological organization and
some of them are quite fixed there.
Their automatic deterministic systems
and those are things you really,
really practiced and that you can just
run as a routine.
And then above that are the.
Are those things that you've chained
together but they could be chained
together in different ways.
So they're less automatized and then you
keep going up.
They get more and more complex and less
automatized until out the top,
which is where your consciousness is
roughly speaking,
your,
you have to program what you're doing,
you know,
and you have to pay very careful
attention to how to go about doing this
because you don't have the systems built
into you.
So know what that's like.
If you're trying to learn something new,
it takes a lot of energy and you really
have to pay attention,
pay attention,
and then once you start to get it,
you know,
well,
there's things.
What really happens is those things you
don't have to think about anymore.
And thank God for that because you know,
first of all,
you can't think that much because you're
a pretty limited capacity process or in
second,
the programming is quite difficult.
Okay,
so,
so let,
let's see here what I've got.
Yeah,
that's what.
Okay,
so if you look on the right there,
there's a little diagram that's a
hierarchical guy or a little table
really,
and it's talking about the motor system.
Now the motor system is what allows you
to put action and like you're out
putting action at all sorts of levels
that you don't even realize because you
know,
you might think that that site is a
sensory activity,
for example,
but that there's a very tight
relationship between sensory activity in
motor activity.
So for example,
when you're looking at a scene,
even though you don't know what your
eyes are going like this,
and the reason they're going like that
is because if you held your eyes
absolutely still and you can actually
learn to do this,
if you hold your eyes absolutely still,
your visual fade right out and you won't
see anything.
And because of the little,
the little,
uh,
retinal cells that are picking up the
light get exhausted.
And so then they stopped transmitting.
And so part of the reason you're zipping
your eyes back and forth is so that,
you know,
different parts of your I can process
the scene and it doesn't get exhausted.
And plus you're also looking around,
you know,
and you're looking at when things move,
when you direct your attention to that
or if someone makes a gesture and so
you're actually kind of using your eyes
like tentacles you know,
to,
to check out the,
the,
the information that's coded in the
light even when you're here and that
sort of thing.
There's a fair bit of motor activity
associated with it.
You turn your head unconsciously and
there's all sorts of little motor
actions in your ear that also helps you
tune in.
And so those things are tightly
associated.
But roughly speaking,
the motor output is action.
And then Swanson shows that there are
these layers in the nervous system that
go from the spinal cord upward.
The first ones are the somatic motor
neuron pools and the second are
locomotor pattern generators in the
third,
our local motor pattern initiators.
And then the fourth r locomotor pattern
controllers.
It's a hierarchy.
So the way to kind of lay piaget on it
in some senses,
to think of the somatic motor neuron
pools as simple actions that can be
implemented automatically.
And then the locomotor pattern generator
has taken those simple actions and chain
them into relatively more complex
melodies of action.
So kinetic melodies and then the
locomotor pattern initiator,
more or less decides windows kinetic
melodies should be implemented and even
that can be unconscious.
And then so it's still at that level of
brain organization.
It's still more or less automatic even
stimulus response.
There's a way to think about it.
And then you go one level higher and
that's where you get the ability to
voluntarily use these automated things.
So I can show you an example of how this
works.
So this is called a ballistic movement.
So I'm going to take my hand and I'm
going to bring it down really fast,
right towards that itch.
Okay.
So all right.
Now.
So that's very fast movement.
Now,
one of the things that's cool about that
movement is that I don't have time.
Once that action starts,
it happened so fast that it's done by
the time the,
the information about the action
actually gets to my brain.
So I actually,
once I let that go,
I can't control it.
What I basically am doing is
disinhibiting the motor control systems
that are already have established in my
psychophysiological being.
I'm disinhibiting one of those and then
it runs automatically and so that's what
you're doing all the time when you're,
when you're acting in life and it's kind
of a neat.
I wrote a paper a while back with an
undergraduate student divine who's who,
so he was a pretty break character and
we got invited to do a paper.
I got invited to do a paper on free will
and so we were thinking about free will,
you know,
and it's very interesting to think about
freewill in relationship to these
hierarchies because it sort of goes like
this.
Is that out there in the future you've
got free will,
but as the future moves towards the
present,
you don't like.
Once it gets close enough to the
present,
you have to have initiated something
automatic.
That will happen.
And so I can give you an example.
People who play the piano very well,
they look ahead of where they're playing
in the music because they know how to do
this.
They don't have to think about it.
What they have to do is look ahead so
that the part of them that knows how to
do this gets ready to do it,
and all of you are experts in that way.
Likely all of those of you who drive,
you're also experts that way because
when you're driving,
where do you look?
If you're a good driver on the highway,
you looked like at least half a second
or a second ahead.
Why?
Well,
because 50 feet ahead has already
happened,
right?
It's too close in time for you to do
anything about it.
So basically what you're doing is you're
looking at the road and then you're
disinhibiting sequences of action that
are the ones that are going to
correspond to what you want to do with
the road most,
most adequately.
And as you know,
the closer you get to executing one of
those motor behaviors,
the more automated automated it is.
So by the time you manifest the auction,
there's no free will there at all,
but you are.
You said enough to be released in some
sense.
So I could say,
well,
this isn't.
There's no free will in that,
but there was in deciding to do it at
that point,
so and so that's sort of how your auto
automative city meets your freedom,
you know,
gotta think about it as something
extending across time.
So,
okay,
so having established that,
then we're going to get into the,
the,
uh,
the more,
the neurological localization a little
bit.
So you might say,
well you collect all these patterns of
behavior and then you automate them into
routines.
I could give you an example.
So for a child,
you know when a child first comes,
when a child is first born,
if you tap on his cheek,
it will go like this.
It's called a rooting reflex and it will
move its mouth and tongue.
But what it's doing roughly speaking,
is searching for a nipple.
And if you just put your finger there,
the clamp onto that and start to suck.
And so the child comes out with that
ability and I'm not a reflex,
it's sort of built into the neurology.
But then when the child starts to
interact with the mother to actually
breastfeed,
well then that initial reflex has to be
modified quite substantially in the
context of the relationship with the
mother because the bear reflex,
it's enough to get the thing going,
but it's not enough to make it work.
And so often mothers take a fair bit of
time to learn how to breastfeed.
But it's also because the baby is taking
a fair bit of time to learn how to do
it.
So they have to establish the dance that
goes with that.
And one of the things that's quite cool
about about that dance,
so to speak,
is there's been studies done of
depressed and non depressed mothers
interacting with their infants.
And so if you take a non depressed
mother interacting with their infant and
you just film them and then you speed up
the film,
you can see like the mothers,
the baby reacts and about the rocks and
baby racks in the mother reacts.
And it's like a dance.
You know,
there's this continual flow of
information between the two of them.
And if the babies with a depressed
mother,
that doesn't happen,
it's Jerky and discontinuous.
And so if you think about that,
you can see how the,
you know,
the dialectical interaction between the
mother and child is building up the
child's repertoire of,
of complex abilities within a social
context.
You know,
I mean,
I know I told you guys before the
roughly speaking that,
you know,
kids really get socialized to play with
each other,
you know,
between two and four.
But that's not exactly true because even
the lower level more automated and more
primordial reflex behaviors,
you know,
like,
like the ones that are associated with
breastfeeding,
even those developed under the
constraints of a,
of social guidelines.
So society is always there right from
the reflex level up.
But you know,
what happens when kids are between two
and four hours,
they have to learn to actually play.
They have to learn how to play complex
games with other children.
And so that's a whole that involves,
you know,
communication and negotiation at a
verbal level and also with people their
own age.
So you know,
it's continuous in some sense of
discontinuous and in another sense.
Okay.
So anyways,
you might say,
well why do you bother streaming all
these things together?
And while you think about the
breastfeeding issues,
well why does the baby bothered to learn
how to breastfeed?
Well,
that's pretty obvious,
isn't it?
I mean,
first of all,
if it doesn't then it doesn't live,
you know,
and,
and there's a bunch of reasons for that.
It's like one is obviously it's not
going to be nourished properly,
although you know there are things you
can do to substitute for that.
Although still breastfeeding still seems
to be the best thing you can do for your
baby,
although you can work around it,
but fundamentally it seems to be the
best thing that you can do.
But then the babies also learning all
sorts of other things,
like it's got skin to skin contact and
it's snuggling and it's being comfort
and it's doing.
I gazed eye-gaze that it's coding in the
mother's imitating it and it's like
there's just a lot of things going on
there.
And so the child is organizing all that
partly to fulfill a basic biological
need,
which is post two needs,
both thirst and hunger,
but it's also fulfilling gets need for
play,
for example,
because children have a circuit for
place.
So you could say play as part of the
end.
It's a fundamental biological need.
The other thing,
children have to have his skin to skin
touch.
They'll die without it.
It's not optional.
You even see that in racks.
So if you take a rat pop away from its
mother and you feed it,
but you don't do anything with it,
it just dies.
It's,
it goes into opiod overdose,
roughly speaking.
It's gastrointestinal systems shut down
and then it dies.
And you can stop that from happening by
isolating it,
feeding it,
and then like massaging it with a
pencil,
with the eraser,
end of a pencil.
You can keep the rat pup alive.
And,
uh,
Jaak Panksepp was one of the people who
either discovered that over,
worked on it.
Then that work was extended by Tiffany
Fields at a,
in a hospital in Florida.
Some really brilliant work.
She was looking at Panksepp's work on
the necessity of tactile stimulation and
uh,
she thought,
hey,
I bet we could try that with premature
babies because,
you know,
babies premature.
Couple of things that are problems,
I mean,
first of all,
at the end of the term pregnancy through
and that's when babies lay on fat,
you know,
so they come out and they're sort of,
they've got some store storage there in
case things don't get going very well,
you know,
and they're gaining a lot of weight to
that last period of pregnancy.
So if they come out pretty mature then
they're really skinny.
And then what happens often is they
start to lose weight and that's not good
because they should be ramping up the
weight gain really quick.
Like a newborn baby.
The elk are roads closed in one week,
you know,
those things are there.
They're gaining weight quickly to do the
premature babies lose weight and you
know,
it's hard to keep them going.
They put them in an incubator,
they feed them.
But what tiffany field did was she had
the nurses go in there,
you know,
with,
with gloves and massage the babies for
10 minutes,
three times a day,
and those babies gained weight as fast
as babies that were still in utero and
you could still detect the differences
in their development six months later.
Which in baby terms is like forever,
right?
I mean you change as much from zero
months to six months as you probably do
from six months to 20 years old.
It's such a radical transformation.
So,
okay.
The reason I'm telling you all this is
because you lay out these hierarchies of
behavior that are well-practiced and
automatized brought under the control of
social conditioning,
but you really do them in the service of
of.
Well that's the question in the service
of we'll say biological necessity for
the sake of argument while you have to
eat and you have to drink.
And so one of the ways,
one of the reasons you lay out the
hierarchy that's associated with
breastfeeding is so you can do that
directly,
but also so that you can establish a
relationship so that not only are you
doing it directly this day,
but you're also going to do it tomorrow
and the next day and the day after that.
And so the hunger system is integrated
with these other systems have a
biological constraint in some sense,
and they're trying to come up with an
answer to the continual problem.
So you have dedicated biological systems
that help you address problems that are
associated with your biological nature
that are universal.
And those would be the things that Freud
would describe as the end.
So you can think of these hierarchies of
motor behavior which sort of develop up
into sub personalities as nested in some
sense inside motivational states.
So there's the motor behavior hierarchy
that you use when you're angry.
There's a motor behavior hierarchy you
use when you're distressed and kids get
very good at that,
you know,
so they'll cry,
which is reflex.
But by the time they're about to,
they're pretty damn good at crying,
you know,
they've got a,
they've got a cry that sounds like
they're sad and upset when they're
really angry.
And so if you really listen,
you can hear the difference because baby
angry baby sounds different than a sad
baby.
But if you don't listen,
the baby will have you think.
And it's sad.
No problem.
Then you'll feel sorry for it and go,
you know,
help it out.
Really,
it's just thinking up years.
So we know this partly because.
So let's say you've got a baby and it's
under nine months,
six months old and it's crying and it's
crip.
You think,
well,
what do you do?
Go in there and you pick up the baby and
you're comforted.
And you probably do that pretty much
nonstop.
When the babies that young,
you know,
because they're so young,
they should really still be in utero.
They're really young.
But by nine months that may be starting
to get smart.
And so it's about nine months when it
can visually recognize people he knows
and,
and people,
people here she doesn't know.
And so then the babies in there and
it's,
you know,
squawking a bit and so wants some
attention and then someone walks in and
it's not the mother and the baby bursts
into tears and people think,
oh,
that baby's all sad because it's mother
didn't show up.
It's like it's not sad.
It's really irritated that the wrong
person showed up and you can tell that
because people have done facial coding
of the baby's expression and also with
skin tone and an angry baby looks angry
first of all and it turns all red.
It's like it's really angry and you see
that behavior later too.
And temper tantrums like a two year old
is having a temper tantrum.
It's just having a fit of rage.
The rage system,
because there is a rage system,
is just completely out of control.
It's just absolutely dominating their
behavior and you don't really want to
encourage that because the rage system
should start to be modulated by other
systems and other higher order control
systems.
Not so much suppressed or repressed,
which is sort of how the Freudians with
thing,
but integrated into more complex and
sophisticated modes of action so the
child can use its anger,
which is an extraordinary and useful
capacity,
you know,
because it allows you to defend yourself
so the child can learn to use that in a
sophisticated way so that it can solve
the problems that would lead to a range
attack without ever getting to the point
where it has to be enraged,
right?
That's a functional child.
It's not like it's learned to repress,
it's anger,
it's just that it gets along with
people.
It never has to get angry.
So now some kids learn to repress their
anger because you know,
they're in a household where any
manifestation of anger is dealt with
very,
very harshly.
You know,
and maybe there's a rule that everyone
has to be nice to each other all of the
time.
You or else sort of a paradoxical rule.
But anyways,
you can imagine now there's a lot of
these biological systems.
And so I want to show you some of their
instantiation here.
So let's look at this one.
So when you get up above the spinal
cord,
there's a little brain area I'll show
you about how big it is.
There it is.
So there's your brain,
the the top one part of the part on top.
That's the cerebral cortex.
That's the part that people are really
proud of.
It's like,
Oh wow,
look at our cerebral cortex,
you know,
doesn't have a lot of neurons.
And then in the middle there there are
older brain areas of genetically old and
then as you go down towards the spinal
cord,
they basically get older and older and
older and older.
So and more and more critical to your
development.
So the serotonin system,
we talked about it a little bit in
lobsters,
right?
Serotonin system is the thing that sort
of determines where a lobster is in the
dominance hierarchy determines whether
it stands like this or whether it stands
like this.
That's an old system.
And when your brain is developing in
Utero,
this serotonin system that guides its
development.
So that's how important it is.
It's sort of like the conductor of the
orchestra,
but it's also the thing that controls
the entire unfolding of the brain and it
comes from,
you know,
really,
it's a really,
really archaic system.
So in some sense you're,
you're,
you're being is controlled by these
things that are ancient beyond
comprehension,
you know.
Anyways,
you look at the Hypothalamus,
you think,
wow,
that's not very big,
and uh,
yeah,
it's not.
But if you take a cat and you.
So cat bring looks,
something like that,
if you take off all the stuff that's in
light orange and most of the top of the
stuff above the hypothalamus that's in
white,
just take all that out.
It's a female cat and it's in a cage.
You really can't tell the difference
between Ada and the cap that has all the
rest of that brain.
Now there's some things that can't do.
It doesn't do very well if you take it
into a new situation because he can't
learn more.
More importantly,
in some sense,
it can't remember.
So it's in a perpetual state of
everything happening for the very first
time,
but it's still capable of a lot of the
reactions that would be necessary in
order for you to stay alive so it can
regulate its liquid intake,
can regulate its food intake,
it can react sexually.
It's capable of defensive aggression,
although it'll really fly into a rage.
And so it's Kinda like a disinhibited
two year old in some sense,
you know,
and uh,
as long as you keep it in the cage and
provide it with food and water,
it's like the way it lives.
And it's hyper exploratory,
which I think is just weird beyond
belief.
It's like you take the brain off a cat
and then all it wants to do is explore,
which is not what you think at all.
It's like a cat with no brain is really
curious.
It just doesn't make sense.
But it does actually because the systems
that drive your exploratory urge are
rooted in the hypothalamus and they're
actually the same systems.
The,
it's,
it's a individual differences in the
function and sensitivity of those
systems that are in part associated with
individual differences in extroversion,
so extroverts sort of hyper exploratory
in social situations,
whereas introverts aren't.
And the exploratory circuit that,
that has its origins in the hypothalamus
runs on dopamine,
roughly speaking,
and then it runs through the base of
your brain and then up into your,
up into your prefrontal cortex in
particular.
And it's also the system that responds
to cocaine and amphetamines and other
drugs that people like to take because
they heightened positive emotion.
So,
so it's very ability at a very,
very low level in the brain that
determines things like the differences
in extroverts and introverts.
So anyways,
it's this tiny little part of the brain
yet,
you know,
if that's all you have,
you can get along.
Not too bad.
Um,
so,
but that's also because it's tiny from
one level of analysis,
but it's really big from another,
you know,
I mean you can,
you can increase your resolution when
you're doing brain analysis all the way
down to the molecular level and still be
looking at the brain,
you know,
below them amount like you level at the
atomic level.
It's sort of,
well,
everything's made out of atoms,
but the brain is already there at a
molecular level and it's insanely
complicated at the molecular level and
the hypothalamus is way bigger than a
molecule.
And so even though it's small compared
to the rest of our brain,
it's still a whopping big structured by
atomic standards.
And so there's a hell of a lot going on
down there.
And you notice the Hypothalamus,
you might say,
well,
is there such a.
You said,
is there such a thing as the ID?
Well,
yes,
no.
Is it in the brain?
Yes and no.
It's really low resolution
representation of what's in the brain.
That's one way of thinking about it.
But then you might say,
well,
is there a hypothalamus?
And the answer to that is,
well,
yes and no because there's a
hypothalamic structure and you see it's
made out of a bunch of things that are
different.
And so you could say,
well,
should you even group those things
together?
Well,
the answer to that is,
it depends on why you're grouping them
together,
you know,
if it's useful for some purpose of
understanding or control to group them
together.
I mean they're,
they,
they are similar in the way that they
emerge in the course of brain
development and they're roughly of the
same phylogenetic age,
but there's lots of reasons to treat
them as the same.
And there's lots of reasons to treat
them as different.
It depends on what you're trying to do
anyways.
The hypothalamus has all these little
sub what,
what do you call
sub structures that are really in some
sense that the core of the sub
personalities that we talked about.
So for example,
um,
okay,
so this is,
this is Swanson again and he's showing
you this is a rat's brain from the
bottom and he's showing you the layout
of the hypothalamus.
You see it's got all those different,
um,
nuclei doesn't look like one thing,
it looks like a bunch of things.
And so here he says,
the descending paraventricular nucleus
is involved in the control of eating and
drinking and that's shown in green.
So that's the thing that when you get
hungry or thirsty,
that's the thing that's sort of turns on
you're hungry and thirsty,
subpersonality.
And then the rest of the cell groups
play a major role in controlling two
classes of social behaviors that his is
involving interactions between animals,
reproductive as the red areas and
defensive,
the purplish areas.
So now what you can think is you have
all those little sub routines that were
talked about,
you know,
that are sort of at hand and ready to
go.
And then they're organized underneath
these major classes of motivation so
that you have to do something like eat.
And so they,
the,
it's like there's an eating robot in
you.
That's one way of thinking about it,
except it's smarter than that.
And it's alive and conscious.
You know,
these things are alive.
They're not machines and they're not
deterministic.
They're just subbed there partial.
You can pick them as low resolution
personalities or unit dimensional
personalities because the only thing the
eating system really cares about is
whether or not you eat and the drinking
system is the same thing you know you
see malfunctioned sometimes in people
have these singular system so you can
develop a condition.
If you have hypothalamic damage where
you you'll drink yourself,
you'll drink water until you die and no
one can stop you.
You know they could lock you in a room
away from sinks and that would stop you,
but you'd be raging away inside trying
to claw through the door to get to the
damn water because you're so hyper
thirsty that it's all that there is left
of you in some sense that if you're
allowed access to a tap,
you'll just drink and drink and drink
and drink and drink and drink and drink
until you drown.
And you know,
people can say,
Hey,
you've had enough water.
It's like,
forget that.
The hypothalamus is a major league
system and when push comes to shove,
it's the thing that's in control.
And one of the ways of thinking about
the way that you organize your,
your life is that the hypothalamus
controls the major motivational systems.
We just talked about those.
And so those are the things that people
would think about as drives,
although they're not driving,
they're too complicated to be drives.
And then there's other systems that come
up later that we'll also talk about that
or eat that governed emotion like
anxiety and a and a different system
that governs pain.
Partly what you're trying to do as you
organize your life is to make sure those
systems stay shut off.
And then you think,
well,
I'm in control.
It's like,
well no,
you're not.
You're just satisfied all of the things
that could take control from you.
And so now you have a modicum of choice.
You can.
And basically what you're doing when all
of these things have had,
what they need is you're running around
exploring,
you know,
and that's,
that's also another one of these
circuits because the hypothalamus,
as I already said,
governance,
exploration.
So a lot of see all psychologists often
get things backwards and they ask silly
like why are people anxious?
That's a stupid question.
It's how people,
why are people ever calm?
That's a question because it's like,
why are you anxious?
Well,
think of all the terrible things that
can happen to you and they will happen
to you even worse.
And there isn't anything you could do
about it.
It's like,
why aren't you quaking in your boots
just sitting there?
Well that's a mystery,
you know?
And then,
well,
you know,
here you are in your normal state.
It's like,
well no,
this is not a normal state.
People have been trying for 7 million
years like as people to create a
situation so complex and comfortable
that a couple hundred of you can sit
here,
you know,
without having your hypothalamus driving
you towards something and actually just
listened to something for a few hours.
That's not normal.
That's so staggeringly abnormal that,
that you know,
it's a miracle that the typical person
like.
And for most of human history it's like
you were hungry man.
And that's not the same like you people.
But some of you have probably been
hungry in your life,
but I mean,
what's the longest and is there someone
here who's going without food for more
than one day.
Okay.
Has anybody here going without food for
more than a week.
Okay.
How about three days?
So like are you hungry?
No.
You're hungry when you haven't had
anything to eat for 20 days then you're
hungry,
you know,
so.
And the same goes for thirst and cold
and all the things that were just never
exposed to.
So we know,
we think civilized people are all calm
and nice and easy to get along with.
It's like,
yeah,
well you know,
you have absolutely everything you need
all the time.
So that makes you as easy to get along
with is any completely insane primate
ever get.
So.
Okay.
So the rep,
you might say,
well God,
if you can survive with just the
hypothalamus,
what is the rest of the brain?
And their answer is,
well,
if you're thirsty,
oh,
let's say you're angry.
100 system isn't going to be able to
take care of that.
Right?
So you're hungry.
Okay.
That works,
you're angry,
that works,
but then you have another problem which
is you're hungry now when you're angry.
Now perhaps you can move through those
states.
You watch that,
you see that in two year olds.
It's partly why they're so fun to be
around.
It's like,
first of all,
they're really excited.
They're running around playing and then
you know,
they trip and then they're crying like
man,
and then you poke them and they laugh
and then they want something to eat and
then they fall asleep and you know,
they're just,
they're just running.
They're run by their hypothalamus and
it's really fun to see because they're
so alive and so enthusiastic and
spontaneous,
but they're completely clueless.
It's like you take one who throws his
creatures to the mall and leave it there
and it's like,
it's just not happy at all and the
reason for that,
well,
it doesn't know how to sequence any of
its actions,
right?
It runs through these states of ne,
but it isn't complicated enough to
figure out how to address those needs in
any consistent sense across multiple
environments.
In a social world.
You need the rest of your brain for that
and so and that again fits in with the
Piagetian idea is that what you're doing
is you're taking these micro
personalities that are basically
instantiated within the hypothalamus and
then you're organizing those into more
and more complex games and you need the
cortex to do that because the cortex is
partly what enables you just to think
about time,
you know,
because the hypothalamus is.
It's all right here and now thing like
the hypothalamic cat lives in the
present.
There's that president and now see it.
No,
you probably get some sense of that.
Like there are one of the things that
happens to people if they take
unfettered means or if they take
psychedelic drugs,
is that some of the inhibitory control.
Some of them are complex control systems
that are critical shutdown and so then
they enter a state where it's all now
and you know the now just comes at
people in that state.
It's a transcendent experience.
But of course you know,
just fight that you're not functional.
And so in some sense you trade that
transcended relationship with reality
for a narrow functionality and that's
too bad,
that's life,
but you know,
it's,
it's a,
it's a tradeoff.
So anyways,
you're organizing these sub
personalities and you're using your
cortex to do that because you know,
you don't just have to think about
eating,
you have to think about how am I going
to get the food,
when is the food going to come,
how am I going to cook the food,
what about all the other people that
want to eat,
how do we regulate that in our family?
And then how do we regulate that with
the fact that we also need to sleep and
we need to work and we need to get along
with other people and we need to have
something interesting to do and like
it's ridiculously complicated and it
really doesn't.
There's no end to the complication
because
you know,
maybe you're just solving the problem
for you then too.
Or maybe you're trying to work it out
within your family.
Well then that sort of like the chrome
brothers,
they never get out of their family
because they just never come to an
arrangement that works well enough so
that they can,
you know,
in some sense move into the broader
world.
Then you solve the family problem,
but then you've got the,
like the tribe problem and you know,
maybe you can solve that to some degree,
but then you have the broader political
problem.
It's like,
you know,
there's an infinite number of problems
that crop up for you to solve,
so there's plenty for you to do with
your big cortex and when we paid a big
price for that thing,
because once we discovered time,
no,
we could make a bargain with the future,
which is basically what you do when you
regulate your behavior.
You're making a bargain with the future.
You say to yourself,
if I forego so and so now than later,
oh,
it'll pay off.
And that's real useful.
You can conceptualize the future and you
can conceptualize the future as
something you can bargain with,
but there's a cost to that.
One is you can't,
you don't get to do just what you want
right now,
and of course that sucks.
It's partly why people drink alcohol
because alcohol is disinhibiting.
It stops you from thinking it actually
doesn't stop you from thinking about the
future by the way it stops you from
caring about what you think about the
future and that's just as good and so
then you could go out and have fun
because fun is impulsive and often
extremely dangerous because the longterm
consequences can be really devastating,
but it's a real pain to keep yourself
controlled all the time,
you know,
because you're foregoing direct reward
constantly.
You know,
I think it's part of the reason why
people in heavily industrialized complex
countries aren't necessarily happy.
It's like,
you know,
it takes a lot out grinding away to keep
all the machinery that keeps all of this
in place going.
You know,
so you're not getting typhoid and know
tigers aren't tearing you apart.
But by the same token,
you have to be unbelievably disciplined
and ready to act constantly to keep
everything that's so complex around you
work it.
And that's not necessarily fun.
So,
okay,
now let's look at something else.
Now you can tell me if I took,
if I showed you this,
I hope I didn't show you this.
You see that?
Okay,
good.
Now some of you know this and so you
just don't say anything,
although you probably don't know this
specific version.
So you're gonna if you've seen this sort
of thing before,
you're going to think you're smart while
you're watching it,
but it'll probably still trip you up.
I hope so.
Give me a sec here at all.
See if we can actually get some sound
out of this thing.
The monkey business count.
How many times the players wearing white
pass the ball?
The correct answer is 16.
Did you spot the gorilla for people who
haven't seen or heard about a video like
this before?
About half miss the gorilla.
If you knew about the gorilla,
you probably saw it,
but did you notice the curtain changing
color or the player on the black team
leaving the game?
Here comes the gorilla and there goes a
player and the curtain is changing from
red to gold.
What you're looking for a gorilla,
the monkey learn more about this
illusion and the original gorilla
experiment@invisiblegorilla.com.
Yeah.
So that's quite a.
that's quite illustration.
So one of the questions you might ask
is,
well,
okay.
First of all,
how many of you didn't see the gorilla?
Okay.
How many of you have seen this sort of
video before?
Okay,
so you knew about the damn grill of the
people who didn't know about the
gorilla.
How many people didn't see the gorilla?
Okay,
fine.
How many of you got the other things?
Both of them.
Okay,
so you get the point.
The point is,
and it's brilliant instrument,
it's an insanely brilliant experiment.
You're blind to a ridiculous degree and
your visual system and your brain are
constantly coping with the fact that
you're blind.
You know,
I mean you can kind of detective to some
degree,
like if you look at someone but you pay
attention to the things that surround
them.
You'll see that like,
so I'm looking at you.
I can't see your nose for sure.
It's gone.
I can't see your face.
I can see your glasses.
I can't see any features in your face
goal.
Can you smile?
The one behind so.
Well,
one of the things I've noticed when
doing this is that like if you look
here,
look at my finger,
but pay attention to my face.
It's really hard because normally when
you pay attention,
you move your eyes to what you're paying
attention to.
Okay?
So here's what you might say.
The first thing you might see is that
you can't see my nose.
The second thing you might see is that
you can really see my eyes,
especially if they moved.
God.
It's so weird.
It's like all of a sudden these eyes pop
up.
Yeah.
So we'll try this too.
Okay,
so look at my finger again.
So you can also see teeth.
Well,
why?
if you're looking here and there's
something there with eyes and teeth,
you should probably be able to see it.
Right?
And so what that basically means is he
bought this tiny little phobia,
which is right in the center of your
retina.
It's just densely packed with cells and
then those cells transmit information
along the optic nerve and they're just
connected like mad to cells in the
visual Cortex,
but you don't have that much room so you
can connect all of the cells in your
retina to 10,000
cells.
Like at the first level of connection
you'd have to have a brain this big,
you know,
and you don't.
So you get by and part of the way you
get by as you're always moving your eyes
around and so it looks like you can see
everything but you can't.
In fact,
I'll hear like if I'm looking at you
now,
I can tell them my hands are there.
Although if I didn't know they were
hands,
I probably couldn't figure it out there.
There are kind of blurry I would say.
And they're in black and white,
but I can't tell that you know,
so out here it's like who cares what
color it is?
So you just don't see the color but you
don't know that you don't see the color.
And then of course I can have my hands
here and then I put them here,
I can hardly see them.
And then they're gone.
They're gone.
It's like they don't even exist.
It's not even,
you know,
because you think in some sense that
what was behind your head would be
black.
Like when you close your eyes,
that's nothing but no one knows.
What you can't see behind your head is
so not there that it isn't.
You know,
it's literally,
it isn't even not there.
That's all gone.
It is.
So.
Okay.
So part of the way that your eyes work
is that the periphery is attached to
devices in some sense.
And some of them detect lines and some
of them detect movement.
You remember Jurassic Park don't move,
the dinosaur can't see you unless you
move.
It's like,
yeah,
frogs are like that.
And cats are like that.
To some degree.
They can really see things move this way
because of the risers slit.
It makes it easier for them to see
things moving like this.
They're not so good at things moving
like this.
Well,
it's because they chase mice,
right?
And most mice,
you know,
except like ones that they moved this
way and so cats are specialized for that
and so you're also specialized to see
teeth and an ice because you want to
know if something's looking at you and
you want to know if it has teeth.
And so what that means in part is that
the surrounding tissue in your eyes
reports to some degree to your visual
Cortex,
which is what you used to actually have
conscious vision with,
but a lot of it just dumps down into the
some of the brain areas we haven't
talked about.
Not necessarily directly down to the
hypothalamus,
although I suspect it has the inputs
there.
I just don't know.
But your eyes talk to your spinal cord
directly so that you could see something
snake light,
for example,
in jumped,
just like your.
You jump.
If your hand touches a hot stove,
you don't even see the snake snake junk.
And the reason for that is you waiting
around to see the snake.
It's like it's bitten you 15 times and
your dad.
So you can't wait around and see this,
oh look,
a snake.
And you jump,
it's like,
no,
that doesn't work,
so your body has conserved all these
layers of reflexive movement all the way
up to a higher order voluntary movement,
because otherwise you just wouldn't be
fast enough when something super fast
happens and then the way your eyes are
built so your eyes can tell your body to
jump if no vision,
right?
It's just pattern,
snake pattern jump pattern,
snake pattern,
retinal pattern,
optic nerve pattern,
brain pattern,
muscle pattern,
no vision,
no.
See,
because you don't need to see it.
You just have to do pattern pattern
matching,
right?
It's a weird way of thinking about it,
but it's not much different than the
touching.
You know,
you can feel the pattern.
You can build a three dimensional
representation of it.
You can really see well with your eyes.
It's like the idea that blind people
can't see as a really dopey idea.
It can't see color and they're not very
good at detecting things in the
distance,
but they have a visual world.
It's just built out of things that don't
have color.
You know?
You know perfectly well that that's the
case because I could hand you an object
and you can fiddle around with it behind
your back and after some fiddling around
he knew exactly what it looked like and
you know,
you might pull it out here and say,
well,
I didn't know it was blue.
It's like,
yeah,
okay,
fair enough.
You didn't know it was blue,
but you still saw it and you can get
pretty God damn good vision with your
ears.
So there are kids who are blind who've
learned to echolocate.
So they go click,
click.
They don't make that noise exactly.
But they do click and they can detect
the clicks bouncing off of things and
they can do that well enough.
Not only to walk,
but some of them can actually ride
bikes.
It's like,
hey,
that's impressive man.
So,
so what's that?
Yeah,
there's one kid,
I saw a kid on youtube who was blind who
could shoot baskets.
Yeah.
Which is thought,
hey,
that's impressive now.
But you know,
my point is,
is that,
you know,
a lot of the neural tissue is intake.
Whatever input it gets.
And so if you're born blind,
your,
your auditory systems will invade your
visual system and then you have twice as
much brain devoted to your hearing.
So,
and then you know,
you can use that quite effectively.
So.
Alright.
So I think we're probably pretty much
time.
The one thing I want to tell you before
we go onto the next part though is that,
so now we've sort of built up the idea
of these underlying motivational systems
and now you can kind of see how they
work.
So you might say to yourself,
why didn't you see the gorilla and the
curtain and the person leaving?
It's really complicated.
Well,
the first answer is you did what I
asked,
and then you might ask,
well why?
Why did you do what I asked?
I mean,
you miss the damn gorilla,
right?
It's like,
obviously that wasn't a very good
decision.
So you think,
well why did you do what I asked?
And the answer would be,
well it's sort of like the milgram
obedience experiment except lower level.
It's like we've got an agreement going
on here.
You guys are all very sophisticated and
complex game players,
you know,
otherwise you couldn't sit here
peacefully for an hour and a half,
so you're.
You're very well socialized all of you,
and so that means that you've organized
all your motivations into a hierarchy
and that hierarchy is guiding your
behavior.
Here it might be something like,
well,
we need to learn something,
and hypothetically you've come here and
you learn something,
and so you're playing that out,
and then because that's the motivational
state that you're in,
when I asked you to do something,
you're just going to do it.
Well then what's so cool is that as soon
as you decide to point your attention
out something,
what happens is what you see in the
world radically transforms,
you know,
so I say,
well,
count the basketballs and all of a
sudden all you can see your basketball.
So new think no,
no,
I see I'm not blind.
It's like,
wow,
you're a pretty damn blind.
And so that's partly how you can
understand how motivation is a
subpersonality.
Like it has its whole sets of
perceptions and values.
It's like all of a sudden we,
I set you up in a little motivated state
was a complicated,
why don't you know,
but it was just like,
here's the task,
and so you're all motivated,
you're going to do the task properly
for,
for God only knows how many reasons,
and then all of a sudden all that exists
in the world are basketballs.
Right?
And so that that's,
that's it's as if you're,
your goal directed attention has
transformed the phenomenology of the
world and that's something that's really
cool because one of the things that
implies is that what you see of the
world depends on what you're aiming at
and in a real sense that this isn't
something trivial sense.
It means like literally what you're
aiming at.
I'm going to count the basketballs.
It means well,
you're not noticing the gorillas.
So one of the things that you might ask
yourself and this department,
what the phenomenologists were on about
is what are you aiming at and what is it
that what you're aiming at allows you to
see and what is it that,
what you're aiming at?
Blinds,
Youtube and it blinds you to a lot more
than it allows you to see.
And so another thing that you can think
about is like if everything you see
makes you angry and bitter and
resentful,
then you might think,
well,
what exactly am I aiming at that's
making the world organized itself around
me in that manner?
And that's,
you know,
that's very.
That would be a complex from a union
perspective,
a complex would do that.
So it's a set of values.
They're sort of economists,
they inhabit you,
it's a subpersonality,
it's quite complex.
It's got something saving yet you might
not know even what that is because
you're acting it out instead of
understanding it and because you're
inside of it,
it lays the world out for you in a
particular way.
It makes you,
it makes the world look like it's
showing you that what you think is
right.
But it's just,
you know,
if your,
what do they say to the man with a
hammer?
Everything looks like a nail.
Right?
And that's,
that's,
that's one of the things that's so damn
cool about that experiment.
It's like,
really?
I'm really that blind.
I could miss something that radical just
when I'm involved in some dopey task
like counting basketballs.
It makes me so blind to that.
It's almost beyond comprehension.
Well,
so in some ways,
you know,
you skipped between different states of
blindness,
lot of them are biologically motivated.
Then you turn those into a hierarchy and
that sort of your higher value system
and then that thing points you at
something and the whole world lays
itself out around that and the way it
does is it divides the world and do
irrelevant things and so those would
have been the curtains in this
particular example or the gorilla or
even a player in black lift the game
irrelevant because it didn't interfere
with you counting.
So what you look at makes most of the
world irrelevant.
It makes some things,
things that serve you and that makes you
feel positive emotion and it makes other
things.
Things that get in your way and that's
what makes negative emotions.
And so you've got the hypothalamic
systems that point you in biological
directions.
You organize those and then it's like as
you're approaching the thing,
you're aiming at the positive emotion
systems telling you when you're on track
and the negative emotion systems telling
you when something's interfering and
those are actually different
neurological systems,
so they're not in the hypothalamus.
The positive emotion system is to some
degree,
but the negative emotion system,
not that evolved later and there's a
couple of them.
There's one that produces pain,
we'll talk about it more,
and there's another one that produces
anxiety and so we're also now you kind
of understand the relationship,
roughly the relationship between
motivation,
perception and emotion.
No,
they all act together and they're all
dependent in this weird way in,
on what you're after so that you can
think about that for 50 years and you
won't get to the bottom of it.
You know,
the Buddhists say that everything is
illusion,
Maya,
right?
People live in illusion.
Why is what you're aiming at determines
what you see.
So anyways,
it's worth it.